eine diplomatische demütigung für den
deutschen bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier ist heute zu einem eintägigen
besuch nach polen gereist um mit seinem
polnischen amtskollegen duda über den
ukraine krieg und die
flüchtlingssituation zu sprechen von
polen aus wollte er morgen weiter nach
kiew zum ukrainischen präsidenten seelen
ski reisen doch der hat sich heute wie
bild exklusiv zuerst erfuhr schlichtweg
geweigert steinmeier zu empfangen wegen
dessen früherer putin freundlichen
politik ein deutscher bundespräsident
wird zu unerwünschten personen erklärt
das hat es in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik noch nicht gegeben wir
hören mal was frank walter steinmeier
dazu gesagt hat
mein kollege und freund der polnische
staatspräsident an sehr gut hat in den
vergangenen tagen angeregt dass wir
beide gemeinsam mit den präsidenten
estland lettland und litauen eine reise
nach kiew unternehmen um dort ein
starkes zeichen gemeinsamer europäischer
solidarität mit der ukraine zu senden
und zu setzen ich war dazu bereit
aber offenbar und ich muss zur kenntnis
nehmen wahr dass in kiew nicht gewünscht
tja da steht er nun der deutsche
bundespräsident und bahn im studio ist
bild chefredakteur johannes jojo hannes
eine öffentliche abrechnung des
ukrainischen präsidenten mit dem
deutschen
bundespräsidenten ein einmaliger vorgang
ja so ist es und es ist natürlich die
quittung die steinmeier jetzt erhält für
die politik die er bereits als
außenminister gemacht hat wir erinnern
uns es einerseits angehörige einer
partei nämlich der spd die immer eine
offene flanke richtung russland hatte
die die gefahr die von russland aus
gegen nie wahrhaben wollte da hat er
selbst auch eine tragende rolle gespielt
und er ist natürlich darüber hinaus
nicht nur parteimitglied sondern hat als
außenminister auch einige maßnahmen
gefordert und umgesetzt umsetzen lassen
die russland deutlich stärker gemacht
haben nun hat er aber kürzlich selber
eingestanden dass er sich in putin
verschätzt habe und einen fehler
begangen habe ja das ist auch richtig
und die
diese einschätzung dieses
selbstkorrektur hat ja bild auch groß
gemacht weil wir das natürlich auch
anerkennen aber es bleibt eben aus sicht
der ukraine ein unglaublich bitteres
verhalten das sich über viele viele
jahre hinweg gesetzt hat ich meine
thomas hörmann nummer dran dran denkt
schon 2014 begann das mit dem ausverkauf
der gasspeicher in deutschland die uns
russland ausgeliefert haben es setzt
sich fort über diverse nato übungen in
polen die steinmeier persönlich
verurteilt hat als säbelrasseln an der
grenze
und es geht dann natürlich bis hin zu
nord stream zwei einem produkt und einem
projekt das uns vollkommen abhängig von
russischem gas gemacht hat dass russland
sehr sehr reich gemacht hat sehr
erfolgreich gemacht hat unter steinmeier
eben selber auch
unterstützt hat für die außenpolitischen
feinschmecker gibt es auch noch dinge
wie die steinmeier formel da ging es das
ist sehr kompliziert um die abtrünnigen
republiken die sogenannten in der
ukraine da hat er sich als außenminister
versucht einzubringen etwas was aus
heutiger sicht in der ukraine auch als
extrem kontraproduktiv gilt diese
sogenannte steinmeier formel ist immer
wieder ein stichwort wenn in der ukraine
über unseren präsidenten gesprochen wird
der zorn ist also glaube ich
nachvollziehbar wenn wir mal direkt nach
china und holen unseren reporter paul
ronzheimer dazu paul welche
hintergrundinformationen hast du
ja thomas wir haben diese geschichte
heute in fiat recherchiert haben mit 15
verschiedenen
quellen in der ukrainischen regierung
darüber gesprochen und dann bei bild
veröffentlicht das was ich gehört habe
von leuten rund um siemens die ist dass
es eben sehr sehr viele präsidenten
und sehr viele regierungschefs die in
diesen zeiten
hierher kommen wollen die
unterstützung zeigen wollen aber die
natürlich auch für sich selbst pr machen
wollen und am ende ist es so dass
natürlich und das hat johannes ja auch
gerade gesagt die ukraine nicht
vergessen haben wie frank walter
steinmeier als vor allem außenminister
agiert hat aber nicht nur als
außenminister sondern auch als
kanzleramtsminister und wenn ich mit
demenz die in den vergangenen monaten
unterwegs war dann fiel sein name sehr
sehr häufig man hat das nicht vergessen
man hat nicht einmal vergessen dass
jens plötner der frühere berater von
steinmeier mittlerweile im kanzleramt
sitzt und dort scheint das verhältnis
auch er callte auf der anderen seite
sehen die ukraine ist so dass zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt aus ihrer sicht
dieser besuch im nicht stattfinden soll
sie haben nicht ausgeschlossen dass sich
das in der zukunft ändert und man darf
eines nicht vergessen frank walter
steinmeier hat als bundespräsident in
der vergangenheit natürlich schon
seelands getroffen mehrfach war zuletzt
im letzten jahr im september glaube ich
war es in kiew da ging es um eine mine
holocaust-mahnmal wo er mit dabei war
also es gab verschiedene kontakte
verschiedene gespräche zwischen den
beinen ist es nicht so dass célestin
steinmeier von anfang an gemieden hätte
oder immer gesagt hätte den will ich
nicht treffen aber dieser krieg hat
natürlich auch mit dem präsidenten mit
dem man sich etwas verändert er schläft
jeden tag nur drei stunden er hat große
sorge vor dem krieg im osten und
möglicherweise thomas spielt es auch
eine rolle dass er mit seinen nerven
relativ am ende ist das muss man sagen
sowohl richtung usa als auch europa man
hat große sorge dass russland hier im
osten einen anderen einen noch
schlimmeren krieg führen wird gegen die
ukraine und sie sagen 1 und fehlen uns
fehlen die waffen wo bleiben die waffen
vielleicht auch das ein grund warum man
steine unter nicht so
johannes wieder dazu in jedem fall eine
demütigung für den bundespräsidenten ja
das ist es auf jeden fall und vielleicht
dass es ein ganz minimale einwand von
mir würde es der ukraine auch gut tun
hier zu unterscheiden zwischen dem amt
und der person die abneigung der person
steinmeier gegenüber ist natürlich
nachvollziehbar aber ist es andererseits
auch der deutsche präsident den man hier
riskiert hat wobei ich dazu sagen will
das ist ein minimaler einwand von meiner
seite denn das was paul gerade gesagt
hat erscheint mir viel wichtiger viele
relevante in der abwägung das ist ein
präsident der gerade teile seines landes
attackiert sieht der sich völkermord
artigen verbrechen oder sogar einem
völkermord an sich gegenüber sieht der
jeden tag geschichten hört von
vergewaltigte kindern und frauen in
seinem land auch männern und da das ist
da vielleicht dann etwas an der
diplomatischen abwägung mangel kann ich
gut verstehen
aus deutscher perspektive würde man sich
das natürlich wünschen
allerdings
muss man ja auch sehen wie sich
steinmeier gerade dazu geäußert hat
thomas er hat gesagt er wollte dort
hinfahren mit drei weiteren präsidenten
um ein zeichen zu setzen und das sind
nicht eben auch wieder eine typisch
deutsche formulierung jetzt in die
truppen die russischen truppen abgezogen
vor kirche ss einigermaßen sicher jetzt
möchte er hinfahren und ein zeichen
setzen ich weiß es nicht da wird paul
uns gleich sicher noch mehr und
genaueres dazu sagen können aber mein
gefühl ist nicht dass die ukraine gerade
möchten dass politiker kommen und
zeichen setzen mein gefühl ist dass die
ukraine möchten dass ihr panzer schicken
schwere waffen flugabwehrraketen um
weitere morde und weitere plünderungen
in ihrem land zu verhindern auf das
gesetzte zeichen das ist schon wieder da
schwingt schon wieder die deutsche
friedensbewegung mit die deutsche
sozialdemokratische bewegung die ja auch
wahnsinnig viele zeichen immer in
richtung russland gesetzt hat und eine
aggression um es um die andere ignoriert
hat paule würdest du sagen du hast
vorhin angesprochen dass sie längst
nicht ausgeschlossen hat das ist ein
späteren besuch geben könne kann
steinmeier den gesichtswahrend jetzt
überhaupt noch machen
ja steinmeier wurde natürlich riskiert
und ich glaube auch dass das noch eine
heftige debatten auslösen wird in
deutschland sicherlich auf seiten der
spd ich habe bereits mit ein paar
kontakten dort sprechen können die
wirklich erschüttert sind darüber dass
sie lenski diesen besuch abgesagt hat
und natürlich sitzen diejenigen auch im
kanzleramt also welchen einfluss das sie
jetzt hat auch die deutsche debatte was
die ukraine angeht das wird man sehen
aber auch bei aller möglichen kritik
gegenüber selensky will ich immer wieder
darauf hinweisen ich bin jetzt selbst
seit über zwei monaten hier ist
natürlich nicht vergleichbar mit dem
arbeitspensum was residenz gehende
präsident events gehen denn der arbeitet
wirklich 20 stunden am tag und immer
wieder verzweifeln wendet sich an alle
parlamente dieser welt versucht mit
telefonaten runde ohne ende der waffen
hierher zu bekommen und ich glaube es
gibt so momente bei ihm und seinem team
dass wir da ein paar mal erlebt eben
auch in diesen präsidenten gebäude und
an anderen orten die sind immer
miteinander 24 stunden die schlafen auch
tor das dann wenn man erlebt dass man
das nicht bekommt was man unbedingt
braucht um menschen zu retten das dann
auch so eine reaktion erfolgen kann ich
glaube das ist menschlich auch wenn man
das politisch aus deutschland anders
bewerten wird davon gehe ich aus dass da
auch die bewertungen der öffentlichkeit
wahrscheinlich kritisch ausfallen werden
darf man nie vergessen um wen es sich da
geht und unbehandelt und welcher
situation sie lenski momentan ist was
ein künftiges treffen angeht daran
sollten beide seiten unbedingt hier
trifft der begriff mal zu beide seiten
unbedingt ein interesse daran haben denn
natürlich hat die ukraine ein interesse
daran dass deutschland weiter hilft aber
auch mehr waffen schickt und frank
walter steinmeier egal was in der
vergangenheit gemacht hat er ist nun mal
wieder gewählter bundespräsident und
wird das in den nächsten fünf jahren
noch bleibt